hey this is presh talwalkar
alice is looking at bob and bob is
looking at charlie
alice is married and charlie is
unmarried
is a married person looking at an
unmarried person
yes no or cannot be determined
surveys have found that 80 percent of
people get this problem wrong
while you're thinking about it i'm going
to present a similar problem
a drawer has 10 black socks and 10 white
socks
with your eyes closed you draw three
socks
are you holding a matching pair of socks
yes no or cannot be determined
give these problems a try and when
you're ready keep watching the video for
the solution
many people think the answer to the
first problem is c cannot be determined
however we need to work through the
logical possibilities
bob is either married or not married
while we do not know bob's marital
status we should work out each case to
see if the condition is met
one case is that bob is married
in that case he is a married person
who's looking at charlie who is
unmarried
so if bob is married
the condition that a married person is
looking at an unmarried person is true
what would happen if bob is not married
in that case
alice who's married is looking at bob
who is unmarried
so in this case too there would be true
that a married person is looking at an
unmarried person so the correct answer
choice is a yes although we don't know
which married person is looking at an
unmarried person we know that some
married person is looking at an
unmarried person
now let's tackle the next problem
imagine that we draw the three socks in
order
now it could be the case that the first
two socks you pull are both black or
they're both white
in that case you would already have a
matching pair of socks before you even
pulled the third sock
now what would happen if that's not the
case
well then the first two socks would have
to be different colors you would have to
have one white and one black sock
then when you pull the third sock it
would have to be
either a white sock matching the white
sock you already have or a black sock
matching the black sock you already have
the third sock must match one of the
socks you already have
therefore in either case you will always
be holding a matching pair of socks
did you figure out these problems
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalkar and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description